يفوق عدد البشر هنا ما يقرب من
ثلاثة إلى واحد على أرضية هذا
المستودع في دبي ،
إنه أول مركز لإنجاز الروبوتات في الشرق الأوسط
، ويعتقد المؤسس فادي
أحمودي أن هذا
سيصبح المعيار الجديد لتكنولوجيا التجارة الإلكترونية
سيلعب دورًا حيويًا في تشكيل
المستقبل الجديد للخدمات اللوجستية لأنك
ستضطر إلى تقديم هذا المستوى من
الرضا والخدمة
بنقرة بسيطة على الماوس ، حيث
يبدأ العمل الجاد في مراكز مثل
انتقاء وفاء الذكاء
وشحن ما يصل إلى 36000 منتج يوميًا
من الشراء إلى  التعبئة والتغليف الآن
تتم طباعة ملصق الشحن
الرائع يقول أمودي أنه يمكن
معالجة العناصر في خمس دقائق بوتيرة حاسمة
وسط الوباء حيث زاد طلب المتسوقين
لتغيير احتياجات المستهلك لأنهم كانوا في المنزل يريدون
خدمة أفضل
بشكل أساسي ولكي تحصل على
ولاء العملاء الذي تحتاجه لمنحهم أفضل
خدمة
مهدت عملاق التجارة الإلكترونية الآخر أمازون الطريق
للأتمتة في عام 2012. اليوم 50 من
م  يستخدم خام أكثر من 185 مركزًا للوفاء
بالروبوتات ،
لكن معظم العمليات في المستودعات اللوجستية في
جميع أنحاء العالم لا تزال
يدوية بشكل أساسي بما في ذلك دول
مثل الإمارات العربية المتحدة
في هذه المنطقة ليست خيارًا تلقائيًا
لاستخدام
روبوتات كاملة أو أتمتة كاملة لأن
العمالة لا تزال ميسورة التكلفة
واستخدامات تنفيذ الذكاء المتاحة  حوالي 40
روبوتًا لنقل المنتجات التي تقول أمودي
إنها أكثر كفاءة بثلاث مرات من
العمليات التقليدية ،
فإن التكنولوجيا هنا تشبه ما
تجده في أمثال علي بابا أو أمازون ،
لكن الفرق بين الذكاء وهذه
الشركات العملاقة هو نموذج الأعمال لأن
أمازون  يتطلب من البائعين البيع على موقعه ،
iq مفتوح للجميع يمكنك بيعه
باستخدام حساب Shopify الخاص بك على instagram
أو باستخدام حساب Amazon الخاص بك ،
وهدفنا هو بناء نظام بيئي من أجل
تمكين التجارة الإلكترونية لجميع عمليات
التنفيذ الروبوتية الرائدة في iq هنا
مرة أخرى في عام 2019
يقول أمودي الآن إن 12 دولة
أعربت عن اهتمامها بترخيص
نموذجه مما يعني أن الروبوتات قد
تصبح للتو  تيار إليني جاكاس سي إن إن
دبي
[موسيقى]